on reçoit maintenant à lemon
elle est même devenue tout le monde
ouais t'as tout raconter bien
alors merci d'être là parce que vous
détestez un peu la promo enfin vous
l'avez beaucoup dit en tous les cas un
donc la salière ya pas marqué noir sur
des films c'était plus marqué meilleurs
vendeurs mais enfin on est contente vous
on est content de vous accueillir
je t'aime pas plus à une fête c'est une
comédie qui fait rire amon vous êtes
resté au delà de toutes ces années
utopiste un peu de marginal un peu un
peu baba cool on peut dire non un peu
desesperado en même temps la cool non
voilà c'est pas un défaut moi j'étais là
bas aussi un way maintenant on m'a le
côté ouvert tricoter on est des pyrénées
est resté quand même marginale
gauthier parade aux anneaux ne nous suit
pas d'espérer à doumé
c'est à dire j'ai commencéà tellement me
faire chier dans ce milieu on y arrive
et que je suis allé voir ailleurs s'il y
était et vous n'y étiez pas donc c'était
c'était le bonheur
alors c'est vrai que vos coups de gueule
vous ont écarté des studios ou c'est
simplement que justement parce que vous
aviez envie de voir la gueule des gens
ici où c'est un peu le fait que j'étais
un peu insupportable sur les plateaux de
cinéma
non mais c'est parce que c'est une vie
qu'il peut très cher la vie nomade
non on peut jamais rien prévoir il vous
change des trucs tout le temps bon donc
ça peut très cher après il ya les les
toute façon vous triche un peu ensuite
les armes pour vous matraque et où je me
suis rendu compte qu'au fond je vivais
mieux si je travaillais pas au bonheur
quand tu es ma patiente number one de
rien de fou rire match au salon métiers
les convertibles de faire les stars
sandwich pour les couturiers les faire
des dips thing aller aux galates bourrer
la gueule ça vous ça vous ça vous gaver
pour pour être clair non non mais c'est
vrai j'ai pas choisi comme métier ni
vendeuse de film sandwich mais moi je
voulais être actrice bon pied quand on
m'a expliqué que l'actrice était tout ça
et barbon alors donc dans ce que j'ai
fait mais vous regrettez pas quand même
quand vous voyez le succès des jugnot
des claviers des lhermitte des blanchons
quand même bourré aux as quoi ça vous
savez je ne suis pas vous n'êtes pas un
peu envieuse de le menacer
moi je suis tombé dedans quand j'étais
petit donc je sais depuis ma naissance
que la rente sa palme revient sur votre
famille avec peu d'argent
bah oui un petit peu d'argent donc c'est
pour ça que je pense que quand on est né
dans le pognon peut pas y attacher de
l'importance ou alors on est gravement
tard et coin voilà quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup choqué réservé aux ignorants et
eau et aux gens qui sont nés dans la
poubelle je salue mes ex que ces
conneries la g dames par exemple vous
êtes linverse d'année matière elle est
née avec du pognon alors veut plus vous
vous êtes né sans pognon et
j'avais beaucoup travaillé pour devenir
star en avoir oui bien sûr mais je suis
d'accord avec elle c'est vrai que peu
voire beaucoup de pognon et peut être
heureux quoi hein mais j'essaie de ne
pas me tourner la tête non plus je vais
juste continuer de gérer même manqué de
rien à notre côté attention attention
j'adore il ya un an à leon je vois juste
une question pourquoi vous avez refusé
le votre césar passe quand même marqué à
la télé mais je les ai je vais oublier
vraiment un joueur c'est vrai bon
personne ne me croirait tout le monde
rit calme les nerfs entendu j'ai
vraiment oublier le truc mais d'un autre
côté du chemin il faut tu sais jamais
cagnard poussière zain donc de refrains
la burqa bien alors magic johnson quand
même qui m'a un petit peu choqué c'est
que vous dites un moment donné de votre
vie vous regrettez d'avoir fait vos
enfants je regrette d'avoir fait des
enfants mais je pense que c'est si
c'était maintenant pour que en réalité
c'est une espèce de contraintes
intérieures parce que les femmes de ma
génération vous pourrez tellement le mou
depuis l'enfance avec ces histoires de
princes charmants et d'enfants et
c'était un étudiant un horizon
indépassable et que moi je pense que
tout le monde n'est pas n'a pas la
vocation
maternelle je voudrais une vocation tout
à fait particulière et qu'en réalité on
devrait élever les femmes de telle sorte
qu'ils aient vraiment le choix et je
pense pas qu'on ait tout fait pour avoir
des enfants c'est le conseil que vous
donnez à votre fille aujourd'hui oui ils
ont absolument mozilla ma fille si tu te
sens vraiment la vocation maternelle
vas-y foncé je t'aiderai mais si tu as
envie de faire autre chose te sens pas
obligé de ce qu'être mère spa c'est pas
une obligation pour toutes les femmes
très bien merci à lemon je ne fais pas
intervenir alors dont vous êtes ici pour
l'homme de ma vie qui est un film de
stéphane curc sortie le 22 septembre
avec patrick chesnais bruno solo
marianne denicourt jean claude brialy et
vous alors sujet on peut dire ans en
2001 c'est charles qui est jouée par
solo qui va avoir un psy qui est chaîné
une relation fusionnelle avec son
psychanalyste est tellement fusionnel
que d'ailleurs le psychanalyste quand on
sait combien une scène qui me fait
beaucoup rire ou le psychanalyste
attaque à la hache
l'apport de son client c'est très drôle
franchement c'est vraiment une comédie
en règle